the mics are live so am i I hope you're
alive welcome back to Resident Evil your
your daily dose of sophistic your
weekend your weekly dose of
sophistication I'd like my hearty that's
Marrakesh I didn't change her
lower-third
this time thank you she was watching cuz
you're so sophisticated this is probably
the penultimate episode of Resident Evil
Revelations open ultimate and we mean
that that's not in the traditional way
that we say it we're now what do we do
last time let's find out okay also
apologies that with that episode did not
go up from the weekend that was 1,000%
my fault we had a crazy end of the week
I think I was pretty clear
[Music]
I'll try to find a way to delay the seat
Roger that
well we'll take care of the virus oh
right remember they spot the lasers the
lasers yeah Morgan lambs aka Santa Claus
Oh Andy did that room I remember this
so I think you're at the airstrip now
that could be wrong I don't know well
yeah apologies for that episode taking
so long thank you for being patient
there's just a lot of technical
difficulties
also our MPX like our back end stuff on
YouTube was taken forever so this
episode took literally an entire day to
upload for like no reason at all but you
got it done yes maybe he's already taken
Jessica I'm not sure can we get started
already
don't look at my right butt cheek stop
looking at my butt fat snake she
definitely wasn't on it remember she
shot him oh right and they were like why
did you shoot and oh he just moved his
head oh damn it I missed it that's all
right oh you're fat snake it's me crazy
shape stop sinking wait is his plan for
stopping sinking to pray I think he's
just being metaphorical but yeah pretty
much
first you're done yeah
so wait she's leaving me um because she
said there was something she needed
check on her she just said that I don't
know if she's actually leaving you it
didn't okay so I'm going I need to get
higher but I could also can I get there
from the bottom one [ __ ] this stupid map
I think I think I want to go and go this
way I would agree
all right so I'm gonna go up these
stairs right yeah and then I think I
want to go through these doors I'm gonna
double check so I don't want to go
through all this exit side of the
wedding box so I went the wrong way oh
wait hon check to see if there's wedding
box around first cuz number the last
time you were also it looked like you're
on that side oh yeah other side then
okay join anything from this weapon up I
can't use it oh yeah because you have
your own weapons right now that you
haven't been upgrading a fat snake you
stupid son of a [ __ ] that's dog we
gonna axe hatchet kind of thing oh right
how do I use my there it is I wish I
could see it better
so she's leaving me she's already gone
she's left me okay she's gonna kill
somebody else she's a hundred percent
going to turn on me it's so obvious
if I was going up against zombie like
creatures I think I would use an axe
over a sword as well they're like a big
knife what's up with the fog where am I
going
oh yeah I hate that stirs up the stairs
and to the right
I don't know that thing's gonna release
a goo you just know it you know I told
you
oh wait we run Oh you been through here
before run okay
you know very well I can't run in this
chicken it's Rachel
killer is this still I'm still doing it
yeah okay
you're literally retracing the steps of
Jill and Chris last time it feels like
oh those are the explosive ones yes well
they're dead there's always hey Rachel
am I taking a left here yes I am oh damn
not great I think I'm out of heels yeah
check there
this is I can I choose her no I don't
think that I could before I remember all
right got her
that's wasting a lot of them although
listen I'm gonna die
shotgun will stags there enough I'd use
the Dodge
go on I am dead yeah we can't get too
far thirsty it's hard because maybe I
wasn't supposed to run through it maybe
I need to just yeah do it correctly well
that first guy you can run away from but
then after that I would just you mean
the lady no the guy in that like this
room this room Alice I mean like I guess
you might want to kill him so you could
try to scan him for stuff oh I shouldn't
Oh God why is he so fast whoa hear him
ya hear you okay that wasn't worth it
that wasn't worth it have you got the
180 turn - okay listen it's very obvious
what I'm doing wrong and it's not the
180 turn it's everything
hmm
I only have one heel okay it's okay
please muse my heel
okay that's okay I got it we got this um
[Music]
wait I got how to wait oh right I'm dumb
okay so I just want to take a left
do I want to take a right or a left here
where am I
oh that's south yeah what am I supposed
to be doing in this situation I feel
very vulnerable yeah anything scannable
up here I mean if that lady yeah you
could chef turn that room behind you
see there's only items before you run
him so the inevitable enemy up ahead
no that's where you're going I'm saying
check the other room behind you this
room yeah looks like a bathroom I think
that snake
holy [ __ ] good moves there use that
yeah are you kidding
that wasn't worth it I'm [ __ ] supered
oh god no there's something new be a
health what is this behind the toilet in
the other room
oh my god I'm moving your phones or
something it looks like it on the other
side of the wall somewhere this is so
cruel I'm gonna die again no you got it
don't try to run by the exploding guys
I'm sure you figured that out by now but
yeah but when that lady's there it's
really hard for me to yeah
oh is this right is this right am I in
the right area yeah but yeah yes
am I going right here and then straight
out getting lost
wait what maybe you are gone the wrong
eye it looks like there's a staircase or
this whole area is wrong that's not you
got to go off anyway from below you
can't go up from this room I know I said
this floor I meant so I need to go
backward yeah can I like go in here and
like look for health or is it like
pointless oh this is the right way are
you sure yeah why do you say that Wow
they walk towards me
that's goes 10
come on oh I'm heating the wall this
isn't going well for me I'll tell you
that
oh he's gonna kill both him that's right
scan those dead bodies yeah this guy's
out there please don't have that woman
in there I really don't want to die
bridge I've come so far you're the one
who's totally like stealing and lying
I like showing off my legs and shopping
Shawn off my legs on Shawn off that Tosh
please no lady please no ly blessa if
she's here I'm gonna die I think you've
gotten a save point by now wait yes can
there one more time okay nothing like
I'm so dead he sounds like her he does
it freaks me out
okay good yeah by the way you're talking
about a nice Bush
you
she's trying to activate the ship's
self-destruct mechanism to destroy the
evidence she's like no I'm coming Parker
it's me I can't trust you completely not
yet put your gun down Raymond yeah
you're too soft
there's tissue he doesn't have a Kevlar
vest in his brain what if he shot you in
the face that was a risk we were willing
to take classic dumb men femme fatale
Jessica don't worry about dinner now
we're
[ __ ] idiot
you deserve to die he is pretty dumb and
I feel bad because he was tricked by a
two-bit floozy
he got tricked yeah so wait did he just
gets bloated I think so hmm that is not
an A in my opinion that was not an A
effort but I'll take it sweet
damn where Chris and Jill
this is making lists
sorry I'm out of practice July you know
I don't know I don't really think about
Christmas things until November I'm not
used to California
ooh of course there's an escape sequence
with alarm so I have no ammo
[Music]
a box right there get a rifle or
something yeah I think I will
oh nice damage five that would be very
useful so that's the Magnum or is this
the Magnum that's the handgun oh yeah
13:20 holy cow um so I have a rocket
launcher I could take that that'll be
nice
um I don't have any ammo for almost any
gun which is unfortunate I probably
won't need the Magnum so I'll replace
that with a rifle and then I'll just
hope I get bullets how does that sound
sounds good
I'd say you have a decent on a rifle
alright I have yeah and they they're
like one-shot kills oh I could operate
one of them to damage five which would
be pretty good I should do that
which one the handgun or my shotgun or
my maybe the handgun if it'll let you
yeah 80% pretty powerful cow
go to date you can put cool he's like we
really need to go and I'm like just give
me a [ __ ] second firing away one I
can put firing rate to and then go down
you have two more slots neck uh-huh
do you want days yeah just for funsies
okay
where we going dum-dum also what's in
here did I just have him leave
when in India like what's oh I can't use
that all right sorry I'm coming he left
did you see that coming crop computer
chair you can't hide your secret oh
that's the thing I didn't need you later
oh right that's the one where they I'm
going backwards
I remember now cuz they were like we
were trying to destroy the world turns
out someone was going to destroy us the
whole time why is this a Mikey Patrick
where did our watch
thank you I am paranoid now ever since
the laser episode yeah the infamous
don't don't we I keep doing the wrong
song when I want to do Mission
Impossible thank you
did you see fallout it was really good
oh wait I did I saw it on a plane but I
have to say I was like half seeing it
you know I'm talking about you because
you're like in a plane and you don't
have to see anything if you don't want
to yeah you're gonna pressurize to tube
hurtling through the sky you kind of
just like half watch okay I kiss I can't
have that did you see that yeah maybe it
was something good to eat earlier I
don't know you're pretty set on upgrades
I'd say that screams like a horror movie
just barely see them stop closing the
door on me it's rude
you gotta hit guts no it's laughing
um I'm still gonna go this way but now
I'm concerned about it still still gonna
still gonna go okay
blowing up okay but my dick is gone uh
what was that Parker okay oh hi Joe
I'm Parker nice to meet you Joe Oh Jill
you're my favorite customer
[Laughter]
I would have never suspect
oh shoot that she got there definitely
yeah hell yeah
[ __ ] hell yeah
we're not getting past that I probably
should have not shot that thing cuz I
think these guys they're gonna wake up
it's my guess anyway
maybe they won't get up no they got up
yeah hang on there's like two shot Hills
[ __ ] you know what I just realized I
can't scan right now because I'm holding
this dead weight
what a [ __ ] idiot partner so I cannot
get any health
well you just pick it up read you need
to explain oh yeah she does actually
kind of help
right in your wiener oh [ __ ] yeah that
was awesome
what a cool guy got you so good
watch out there's fire oh those things
or any moon no I'm sorry
QX rocket power at all yes but it's been
ages
yeah but I liked it yeah oh no I thought
there was one next to me
oh I keep hitting that metal I was like
wondering why I couldn't kill that gross
thing stop shutting the door yeah I know
yeah I know you're real dead weight and
when I mean dead weight I mean like
mostly like weight you are so fat they
got you never let go Jack
run home run jack
are they gonna have like a heartfelt
goodbye in this situation yeah
Terminator 2 style at the end
shoots her in the face see you later
alligator
kidding and then he comes up on wings
[Music]
okay we should go because he just killed
myself to save us damn he's doing his
passive-aggressive together [ __ ] you
Chris
Oh countdown I guess it is good that I
wasn't carrying that guy anymore
yeah alright it wasn't nice
oh I might have died why did did you
just assume you had to turn that Valve
yeah because the steam was coming out Oh
gotcha
how do I use my grenades again I [ __ ]
up r1
Oh papa blood needed that so bad
what the [ __ ] can I not kill this guy
hang on you were using it's pretty
powerful
stop being nice
oh nice I always thought that
okay she's what's he shooting at was he
shooting at okay good
he's look to you ha made you look oh oh
just okay you have a timer ray ooh
what's in the crate not bad it's a lot
of red flannel pick it up there we are
running out of time
Oh balls
all right throat
I'll wait idiot
Oh triple bogey listen I know you gotta
get them scans hun good
Oh Oh balls
Oh balls
little quickscope action yup
where are you okay
all right where am I going up the stairs
yeah
that's what this is right right yeah
okay what's going on down there okay
what happened to my partner because I
had one okay cuz he made it
that's gun it hell yeah
god damn it hey there he is he had to
show up at some point we error ready man
yeah okay
Oh Oh your hand gotta be better okay no
no no no shock I don't have a gun I need
to give up I could take another barrel
to the face oh I shot it on a paranoia
oh right okay see I told you it could be
another barrel oh my god this is gonna
be close
I got it what was I supposed to do there
I'm surprised it didn't kill you
what was I supposed to do I got like no
more barrels my god I don't
I didn't make it I thought almost I
thought if I got through through the
door
me too
let's gun it okay so wait what am I
supposed to do in this situation
hey what am I supposed to do isn't the
first point you did fine because you
went to the right side of it like the
father when he said it'd be faster am I
supposed to use the die or no just do
stop moving like keep doing
yeah you won't set is that what I'm
supposed to do yeah yeah if I can't hit
things with a shotgun that's not a good
sign you're already making better time
nice well I mean not really
what yeah you got left side in there but
like I'm shooting it and then they're
exploding on me yeah I think you guys
then
well I'll tell you something I didn't
learn anything yeah
this is brute force yeah you have way
more time this time oh [ __ ] Mikey hey
Mikey
Oh who's that wiser - there's one bad
one of them's for the girl with one leg
Oh got Jessica
stop drop and roll it's this thing again
yusin's on our way out nothing's huge
Jessica Jessica do you look good so you
said 12 episodes right yes but I don't
have time tonight unfortunately I'm just
saying like am I gonna keep going
oh um cuz this is a short episode then
wait how do you know what do you mean oh
I know we've only our episode and in the
last one we can I don't know we'll
figure something out okay
previously on Resident Evil Revelations
destroy the evidence I like to replay
what happened shipmate oh they kidding
keep checkmate I'm coming to town
[Laughter]
chill we have to go I know I know I
barely knew you
good thing there's an like infinite
amount of Mikey clones hey that's not
how it works
the only others calling revelations that
umbrella Corps did was make infinite my
keys and teach them all how to be pilots
I was the original stop staying hat
trick yeah we get it you're happy that's
like Garth wriggle that's like the
nickname he wants so badly for people to
call him yeah sure Curt Patrick out
are they gonna give me like more ammo or
Chris are you okay
oh I [ __ ] killed one of them oh [ __ ]
like honestly what's my what's the
long-term plan here
[Music]
your rifle do damage for sure sure but
yeah I wouldn't you try to shoot those
things like oh yeah don't try to shoot
those things flying at you just move and
dodge like okay uh hold down the fort
deed
Oh some ammo
[Music]
oh yeah no [ __ ] dick
wait wait is that oh [ __ ] I [ __ ]
missed that's unfortunate
oh my god you Dodgson I did yeah good
for me Oh balls he's coming at me
they're big but they're stupid
for [ __ ] sake my weapons better be
okay Wow
well it looks like it almost meant yeah
I not me wait you want to shoot his face
with the Rockets I wonder oh oh you
[ __ ]
don't don't do that okay your call
everybody stand corrected
really I think you got it
wait we did it yeah [ __ ] grenades [ __ ]
rockets [ __ ] thank you all right
Mikey something tells me that's not the
end we did it we beat the game arose
such a clatter turn sequence
I smell yeah daddy says I gots to have
my turret sequence Mikey oh I thought
that was the monster
this is just like Parker Oh Isis nice
[ __ ] move Chris hell yeah Chris hell
yeah Jill [ __ ] that was a cool shot man
sometimes these games are so stupid
ready
oh oh so you're gonna be Chris now
they're switching you over no where do I
shoot it just [ __ ] everything it's
Tennys oh maybe you can't
hold on here but I think this looks at
your honor
oh you got green AIDS I do yeah r1 well
I think so you know yeah but use it on
ah they're growing out of him
I don't know what you supposed to shoot
when they die maybe shoot see where
Chris is shooting orange keep your nose
he said when we started the level to go
for the tentacles so I'm gonna continue
that as if it's like make sense those
would be anything else be too easy to
hit yeah yeah What did he say that's it
take them out just keep doing it
yeah I think this is a husk in the and
the thing is that aren't you a [ __ ]
Sciences I've seen one of these before
and you want to shoot the the wormy
this reminds me of a game I would plane
in arcade hyung-tae mouth yeah with my
actual guns
yes
[ __ ] why I'm gonna try to weave in
between them how would you get your
pilot its Patrick its Hatcher a night
I'm the great ham Dino
well this is going well but it seems
boring there's a lot visually going on
but I wouldn't say that the gameplay is
interesting
he's little goose shut up Mike its hat
trick its know this is hat trick that
was good
do you need my assistance No
remember you got grenades for this part
r1
you know how to treat a girl Oh mouth
ain't the mouth me for that bulbous
thing hold it hold hold what we are
button that was charging that up and
then he'll oh I can't heal yeah I died
you threw off my enthusiasm so much I
didn't know what I was supposed to do
I've never had that gun before
that's a loading kind of gun mm-hmm
nice to do this whole scene again no
this is yeah oh yeah that's real done
that there's no checkpoints right now
sorry I didn't know I had to load I
didn't know I had to like hold it down
Coleco he just never stopped shooting
better than the alternative
just keep pooping out like hot snakes
[Music]
got it
Wow Krista shot that one here right
projectile is
roasters but china's all over him
there's just like these little oarfish i
and they just keep
Oh
I'm doing one of my stick moves again
I don't think this helicopter would
still be in the air
I got it I got it I got it
oh [ __ ] I'm overheating
is it Jud
No
oh I [ __ ] know
they just like keep coming out
it's launch grenades in its mouth
I missed
okay so hold it down X X X X X nice oh
yeah
this ship is my dress like I want you to
see a doctor look like Mike
it's me what's happening on our way out
we lost Parker
and my cheekbones Jessica took the whole
ship down the FBC Morgan was one step
ahead of us the whole way
[Music]
mrs. Moore didn't think this could all
be a mistake with us O'Brien is the last
chapter a flashback right born on a cold
day cold dead April and the Sun was
shining bright and the clocks were
striking thirteen sweet we did it oh
that was not the end of the chapter okay
all right it's 607 go we can finish this
chapter
okay Mike has a hot date I do not
that ecclesia this is Parker and Jessica
Jessica would not dress like that yes
they call it tarik Grisha I think it is
no she's a cutie patootie
she she talks like this because she's
evil and sexual whereas this girl talks
like this because she's nice oh my god
that's of course was a hunter he's dead
oh no he's not now yes I [ __ ] don't
have the ammo for this scan dudes you a
scanner no I'm sure they'll give me
stuff
[Music]
his hairy ankles are veins this is just
the kind of feet he was warning the
world maybe the international community
will finally get the message
if BC has a lot of growing excuse me
miss your hat makes you look like a
Stegosaurus Oh who's saying that Jack
Raven I do not have the ammo for this
suck it up I have two bullets
there you go just gonna do it what's her
name yeah shoot it was doe it's gotta be
Jessica right give me your number
smirking so you don't have a scanner
correct no I do
I'm coming let me just get this ammo
I'll be I'll be right there
oh you guys take care of this warming
Ramon's a cadet I love it when they hop
around like that
oops he's like I'm on a hop closer to
you I'm gonna come get you okay fine I
[ __ ] hurt I'm gonna pee my penis
I need to poop baby nice healthy baby
needs poop out of his like all right man
up touched her she's full up
that's like men's two modes manly men
and boom boom town boom Browntown buddy
[Laughter]
I'm gonna hop over there
it's so weird how they died yeah how
they like disintegrate so Raymond is
it's kind of like a [ __ ] I'm gonna hop
over to you
hoppin yeah you win this then I'm so
[ __ ] slow but what was that my sacred
area
where am I supposed to be going don't
know this is the only door together
you just closed the door in Jessica's
master whoever that is finally it's
gotta be Jessica like I'm just saying
like that girl like it's animated her
voice is different like if that's her
I'm a monkey's uncle
oh yeah [ __ ] who cares not kidding it
literally says budget expenditures
you're not helping your cause Animal
Protection community
it came from right yes maybe yeah I've
up the door itself
what door so you're behind you
that's a garage door kind of thing
Open Sesame oh wait dum-dum okay
we'll go through this door it looks
locked oh there was a bad board meeting
in here looks like someone got fired you
fired
you hired it's not too bad it wasn't
done it was like a crossing Donald Trump
inherit contract you're fired
you're hired is all of this yours no
you're gonna leap over a no trespassing
sign in the middle of an emergency
we should be okay
based on what I know how you died
nice
who
there better not be any frogs this way
you're going through the other door and
then up the stairs a little towel
snapping I told you guys only have two
modes wait nope
ultra uber men's nope yeah mode and baby
boom boom mode a baby boom boom pooping
splatter and [ __ ] hilarious mode in
my case I think that's just baby boom
boom no it's my baby boom boom baby boom
boom scary rowdy baby cat
come over here boy and it's my scratch
my issue with cheeto 0z you've a lot of
health yeah
doing good on that regard but not a lot
of emo
they're in the walls you're in the
windows got you aah
[Laughter]
thought you could leave work early again
eh you back in your cubicle you thought
you couldn't scale me but I'm a big boy
oh they do move in always smiling it's
so creepy
you know they should have given her a
different default face she's got a plan
even back now even back then
are you like just make sure I'm fully
healed
what tourniquet for that guy was lucky
good thing was in this office that you
guys said was the ward to like heal
people pain in the tushy bum bum he
needs a bit more towel snapping if you
know what I mean fine we'll go save
bumble still skin like I knew it was
coming and it still scared me Raymond
that's you damn it the cable is out
gun is bullet but I wouldn't say it's a
joy thanks from done critic Mary catch
its gun bullet II but I'm like it
it's not joyful it's just like there's a
lot more bullets which is nice but they
don't do very much
shot up I wonder if that's ever worked
in um like an actual army scenario where
guys like I'm not gonna make it and he's
like [ __ ] and he's like I order you to
stay alive guys like okay okay so I'm
good
oh I went the wrong way stay alive now
who you made a promise right
oh wait am i dumb okay divide room
whoa
hello
duck legs dick
OOP
what
she says oh she did that cool leg thing
again
kick them belittling him go to him
my anus is bleeding
I'd say rather that's the under Chapter
now's probably good place to stop that's
me apologies for the lost thing that's
cute
[Music]
his hair is awful
it is awful like all the one side the
other side did something to him tell me
a joke what if it doesn't make me laugh
it just saved right there I kind of like
have to leave are you sure you saved it
autosave yeah but that's not probably
good because otherwise the yeah our
final episode wouldn't have enough juice
yes this was the penultimate and
ultimate which means next week is also
they put off the bed penultimate let me
go back to the camera I don't know why
but yeah again sorry about last week
taking so long but it's up go catch up
if you haven't already otherwise happy
rest of your Saturday
record our finale next this coming week
but thank you to everyone who joined as
always and I'm sure Nathan Shepard will
post the discord link in YouTube
anything if you haven't already to be
awesome and then next week we'll go over
the numbers for the final episode and
all the stats yes see you then bye back
can ultimate
pe and when he died place six times he
ult